hi guys I'm Eric Voss and the x-men
movie franchise may at times get
overlooked when Marvel Studios pumps out
three movies and 80 trailers a year but
despite this planned merge of Fox's
x-men properties with all of Disney's
Marvel properties the studio still plans
on six x-men movies in 2019 and 2020 in
addition to the two scheduled for 2018
so what is the future of the x-men
franchise well if it's anything like its
past it's probably gonna be very complex
with multiple actors playing the same
characters he thought the MCU timeline
was confusing this one has three
different strikers and I think they're
all actually mystique so let's break
down everything we know and how any of
these movies might fit into the overall
cinematic universe starting with the
movies we know are coming out in 2018
first on May 18th we'll see the premiere
of the Deadpool sequel Josh Brolin took
a break from playing Thanos so names
you'd co-star here's cable the gruff
time-traveling techno-organic mutant
whose origin is just too complicated to
explain here or anywhere luckily this
channel has already done some in-depth
breakdowns of Deadpool 2 trailers and
yeah I going to cable and O's this movie
will also introduce Daisy beets as
Domino another mutant played by Julianne
Denison and possible setups of the
x-force more on that later and returns
from all the old faces and dick jokes
later this year on November 2nd will be
the release of x-men Dark Phoenix and
it's easy to forget that this movie is
still coming out this year because we
still haven't seen really any trailer or
poster for it yet since x-men Days of
Future past
reset the x-men timeline basically
erasing all the events of x-men The Last
Stand mercifully Dark Phoenix will be a
fresh adaptation of Chris Claremont Dark
Phoenix saga and the Marvel Comics
so this Dark Phoenix movie will be a
follow up to 2016 x-men apocalypse with
most of that movies cast returning
including Jennifer Lawrence as misty and
sophie Turner as Jean Grey continuing to
explore her powers the film will be set
a decade after apocalypse in 1992 when a
solar flare hits the x-men during a
rescue mission in space this movie was
written and directed by Simon Kinberg
longtime writer and producer on pretty
much all of the x-men movies and
hopefully now that he has more creative
control will get really the Dark Phoenix
movie that we really wanted okay that
brings us to 2019 when we
already no one of these movies is coming
out the New Mutants which will release
on February 22nd 2019 originally this
was plan to come out in April of this
year but the studio pushed it back and
the initial trailer that they released
made this movie look super spooky it
stars another game of Thrones actress
Maisie Williams Charlie Keaton from
stranger things
Anya Taylor joy from split and several
other very talented young actors they
play a group of young mutants in a
horrifying shutter island' type facility
Professor X's rumored to appear with the
antagonist being the demon bear a
Stephen King like monster that feeds on
negative emotion and is right behind you
false alarm but never let your guard
down the demon bear is persistent
okay the next movie on the x-men
calendar is gambit with a scheduled
release date of June 7th 2019
Channing Tatum is still attached to star
and a script should be greenlit this
month but the project still seems very
much up in the air Gore Verbinski who
was the third director to take on the
project recently parted ways with it
earlier this year Tatum has suggested in
various interviews that it'll be an
origin story set in New Orleans and that
they were inspired by Logan's success to
do a page-one rewrite with an edgier
tone now those are the x-men movies that
are scheduled but the next one in the
development pipeline is x-force this
will follow the team of badass mutant
soldiers that appeared to join Deadpool
in the last step will - trailer that
includes Terry Crews who many believe is
playing GW bridge it also sounds like
Ryan Reynolds and Josh Brolin will
return it's Deadpool and cable for the
sequel Drew Goddard is writing and
directing this movie he is awesome he
was behind the first season of daredevil
movies like happen in the woods in the
Martian and shows like Buffy and Angel
and he's scheduled to start shooting
this movie in October of this year so
it's possible we could be looking at a
late 2019 release date for x-force but I
suppose the studio will make that call
when they see how well Deadpool - does
this summer and moving on to 2020 where
studio insiders have hinted at three
x-men properties that are only very
loosely in the works the first is a
secret movie currently titled 143
written by longtime Marvel Comics
creator Brian Michael Bendis and
directed by Tim Miller who made the
first Deadpool movie this will be a solo
film for Kitty Pryde 143 could be a
reference to uncanny
x-men issue 143 which featured pride
fighting a demon alone in the x-mansion
of course Ellen Page played Kitty Pryde
in the previous x-men movies but if this
is a new story they're working on for
the character we may get a new actor
playing the part will see another
rumored x-men project that could come
out in 2020 is the Doctor Doom movie
this one's being produced by Noah Hawley
who has done an amazing job with Legion
on FX dr. doom is an awesome villain
maybe the best for the Marvel Comics and
unfortunately he just hasn't really been
done justice in any of these fantastic
four movies that have been made but
looking at the way Halle characterized
the shadow canyon Legion making him one
of the most truly haunting supervillains
I've ever seen in movies or TV whatever
Holly has in store for Doctor Doom is
definitely something we'll want to see
another secret x-men project in the
works is a Silver Surfer solo movie with
the script being written by Brian cave
on co-creator of dozens of iconic comic
series like Runaways saga and why the
last man really these are just a few of
many great characters on the x-men side
of the Marvel Universe that could still
be explored in a movie remember Logan
left us with x-23 leading the BK Kids
Club or whatever that was I'd love to
say whatever a Canadian high jinks they
get into and who knows maybe there'll be
another Deadpool sequel in the works
where we see them like try to hook up
with mistress death like he does in the
comics or a future x-men team up movie
that features mr. sinister as teased at
the end of x-men apocalypse
yes Disney's biota Fox's film and TV
properties does complicate this whole
schedule and maybe we do have a Marvel
phase 4 in a Fox post 2019 they look
forward to where all these Marvel
characters can start appearing in movies
together but for the projects already in
the pipeline these filmmakers are gonna
stick to the solo movies and sequels
they've already been contracted to make
which means before
x-23 teams up with spider-man and Cherie
from Black Panther and some crazy
team-up movie in here 2024 we're gonna
see more Deadpool x-force j-law x-men
creepy new mutants and maybe gambit
Doctor Doom and Silver Surfer as far as
I'm concerned this Disney deal can take
its time but I want to know for you guys
which of these x-men movies are you most
excited for
would you prefer any of them to get
pushed back so Kevin Feige can figure
out how to work them into them see you
comments down below to let me know your
thoughts or tweet me directly I da boss
and follow new rockstars on Twitter for
updates on our videos like this video
and subscribe to new rockstars for more
tales about the superhero movies you
love Deadpool Logan and everything
Marvel and DC related and if you really
want to help this channel you can
contribute any small amount to us on
patreon big thanks to all of our current
donors especially Wilhelmina Edison
thanks for watching guys bye
[Music]